embrace the human elements of you if you
stutter if you sneeze if you say um
every two seconds guilty
just show up as yourself embrace the
human elements where you mess up maybe
or where you sneeze because i sneezed in
a video and i don't know why but people
loved it and just embrace those human
elements because it really again takes
that pressure off your shoulders of
having to be
or show up a certain way
are you nervous to get on camera oh my
goodness i waited over three years to
press record because i was so nervous
and i had such low self-confidence to
actually get in front of the camera the
girl you see sitting here today or
hearing on the audio is not the girl
that i was 10 years ago and in today's
episode we're talking all about the
steps to take to calm your nerves so you
can press record my name is heather
torres and i'm the host of this show
here on the think media podcast the
number one podcast to help you grow your
youtube influence and then turn that
youtube influence into a high impact and
a high profit online business every
single tuesday we are releasing a brand
new episode so make sure that you are
locked in by subscribing if you're
watching on youtube or subscribing
wherever you like to consume this
content on and i want to welcome all of
our brand new listeners here on the
podcast as well i'm so encouraged that
these episodes are helping you
grow your youtube influence and helping
you create the best online business
possible now today's episode is brought
to you by growethvideolive.com
i am so excited because we are in the
countdown to the number one conference
to help you grow your personal brand
using video we have amazing speakers
like gary vaynerchuk chalene johnson
patrick bet david alex hermosie jasmine
star aaron on demand and so many more
that are going to be there to teach you
all about growing your personal brand
and your online business if you've not
locked in your tickets yet you can go to
growthvideolive.com right now to secure
your in-person or your virtual
experience now for all of those who have
already registered it is going to be
such an amazing experience we've got a
poolside party to kick it all off we
have networking events you're going to
walk away with actionable steps to grow
your personal brand using video and can
i tell you that in this year and the
years to come video is only getting
stronger we have experts that are
teaching on all of the platforms
instagram ticktalk youtube and so many
more because i know that you want to be
everywhere so we're going to teach you
how to do that so go to
growthvideolive.com to secure your
ticket today now today's featured
content comes from sean cannell and
modern millie and we're talking all
about how to calm your nerves and how to
get confident on camera let's jump into
today's featured content and stick
around till the end because i'm going to
be sharing with you one of my tips that
i've used over the years to help me look
confident on camera
[Music]
and getting on the camera can be really
scary so how do you ultimately build
your on-camera confidence i'm excited
today because on the podcast we have
modern millie who is an instagram expert
a youtuber who started her channel
really got serious in 2020 and grew to
over 160 000 subscribers so far
as an educator course creator but is
most known for residing in oceanside
california where the weather is sunny
where her and her husband adopted a
terrier named lady off the street modern
millie how's it going it's going great
good to be here thank you for having me
thanks so much for being on the podcast
i'm fired up and we're here at social
media marketing world but our topic
today is camera confidence and yes this
is one of the scariest things right
because our first videos are our worst
videos people wonder when i first get on
camera will it be awkward
yes
absolutely yeah it will
will i not know what to say yeah you
won't know what to say
and so it can be really really
challenging for people so i'm excited
you have three practical tips but a
couple questions to start off
why is it important to put our faces on
camera to actually get on camera
ourselves as opposed to hiding behind
slides or b-roll or something else
the
most important reason for putting your
face on the camera because that's
everybody's biggest hesitation they're
like well i want to grow
but do i have to use my face like you
don't have to use your face
but
it will be very powerful to use your
face because it really is the one thing
that'll build human connection
as humans we seek out
faces everywhere we go like when you
look into the clouds sometimes you'll
just see a face your face is seeking out
that connection so when you put a face
to your brand
that is the best way to make the human
connection make the human
elements pop out and really stand out so
i like to give the example of like when
i say state farm
can you think of somebody who represents
state farm everybody goes oh yeah jake
from state farm because that business
who didn't have to put a face to their
brand they put somebody recognizable
into the forefront of their brand so
that people could immediately create
that human connection so that's really
the biggest reason using your face is so
pivotal
i love that and um when it comes to some
of like obviously your research you
coach a lot of people so you get to get
inside of the emotions that people feel
what are people
un uncomfortable on camera for like what
usually is the source of their camera
discomfort there's two different sources
so you have your external sources and
then the internal sources so usually the
two biggest reasons when i ask somebody
well what's stopping you from getting in
front of the camera there's two common
answers one has to do with the fear of
being judged by other people and that's
the external sources and then the other
one comes more internally where it's
like
i just feel awkward or they just feel
uncomfortable they don't know how to be
in front of the camera because of that
lack of confidence so those are the two
biggest reasons people
stay away from getting in front of the
camera
now did your climber confidence come
instantly or you know talking before you
said that you even had a channel that
you kind of experimented with your
brother now of course you're doing
instagram reels you're doing all these
different forms of content but talk
about your journey like what what was
kind of your progression of building
your camera confidence
i
am
child number four of five
and i think being one of the youngest
you
kind of wanted to put yourself in the
spotlight because you didn't want to be
forgotten not to say that my parents
were like let's forget children's four
and five you know that wasn't the thing
but
kind of ingrained in me was okay how can
i jump in front jump in front so since a
really young age i was always making
music videos with my siblings singing
hit me baby one more time right
and then the love for video started to
really come out in middle school high
school when my brother and i we started
a youtube channel together
and it was weird still like actually
sitting down with a camera pressing
record
and you're like talking to nobody
but in hopes of talking to somebody
right
and
even to this day since i'm thinking back
to when we first pressed that record
button back maybe in 2008 2009
even now 2022
i have my own established youtube
channel when i press record it's still
funky you know there's really
not this one thing like oh if i do this
i'm gonna overcome all of the fear and
all of this awkwardness it's just
getting comfortable within the
awkwardness and being like okay this is
this is just a thing i'm just talking to
a camera and
that's just how it's gonna be
and i love you sharing your journey too
because it has been a journey you
haven't just done it once you've made
all kinds of different pieces of content
and today you're standing in
part of just doing it a lot
lots of repetition yeah lots of practice
and uh it does i mean i i would i mean
it definitely does get easier it becomes
second nature i'm like 2000 videos in
15 years in or something it's just kind
of crazy yeah it becomes easier it like
second nature kind of like talking to
you right now conversational you learn
to have a conversation with an inanimate
object like a camera
but there's still always that you mess
up and you're the underlying oh well i
messed up that was awkward you know
totally that that little feeling is
always kind of there in the back of your
mind 100 and people probably be
surprised how many how much we still
mess up and how many retakes there still
are um even if you've been doing this
for a while yeah but i'm excited to get
into these tips and so three quick
practical tips for just being more
confident next time you're on camera and
the first one is flip your phone can you
talk yes flipping your phone
i notice right now a lot of us we just
have our phones on hand and even if you
want to start a youtube channel
and you don't have anything people are
like oh i need a camera i need a camera
it's like just use your phone but when
you use your phone my biggest tip is to
not i'm just going to show for anybody
who can see and i'll do my best to
explain for anybody listening you have
the selfie camera which is like where
you see the screen a lot of people use
the selfie camera
flip it around and use the back camera
the main camera because then you can't
see yourself and you're not judging
yourself you're able to make eye contact
with the camera which is really what
brings that human connection and you're
not getting in your head because you
can't see you can't judge you're just
talking that's a really good tip and and
also i mean they might have a camera
with a flip screen on it and i guess you
could challenge yourself by getting the
shot right but then putting the flip
screen away so that it's not a
distraction right but also a huge tip is
also make sure you're looking at the
lens the other problem would be if
you're you see a lot of creators
sometimes staring at themselves
and that eye contact actually makes
human connection yes but if you're just
looking off to the side or looking off
to the selfie screen then you kind of
miss out on that so i love that tip
number two
press record with no
intention to post yeah if you're
somebody who's just starting out
and you've never made a youtube video
before or you're making an instagram
reel
you put that pressure on yourself of
like okay well this video has to be
perfect or this video it's got to be
good enough to post right we have that
pressure
well when you record for the first time
take that pressure completely off take
the pressure off
press record to simply press record and
get comfortable in front of the camera
that video that you record doesn't have
to go anywhere you can delete it right
after but just get comfortable sitting
in front of the camera talking to tell a
story
share with yourself your most
embarrassing moment you know and
and just talk to yourself on the camera
it doesn't have to go anywhere so
encouraging okay tip number three
embrace your flaws yes i find that
my
best performing videos both
or with tick tock instagram reels
youtube
some of the most common comments are
when people are like i love that you
kept in that blooper
i love when you sneezed you know like
that was so funny when you incorporated
the sneeze into the conversation you
know and
again people see all of these
influencers or creators youtubers and
they think they have to be a certain way
or show up a certain way so maybe
there's people who look up to you follow
you and they think okay well if i'm
going to be a youtuber podcaster i'm
going to show up like sean i'm going to
show up like sean's like no no don't
show up like shawn shawn's great
he's fantastic use use him as a role
model but don't show up like him show up
like yourself embrace the human elements
of you if you stutter if you sneeze if
you say um every two seconds guilty
just show up as yourself embrace the
human elements where you mess up maybe
or where you sneeze because i sneezed in
a video and i don't know why but people
loved it and just embrace those human
elements because it really again takes
that pressure off your shoulders of
having to be
or show up a certain way so strong
millie um if people want to connect with
you you're a great follow for especially
instagram tips on youtube and on
instagram but where what's your handle
how do we find you my handle on
instagram is at it's modern millie so it
does start with the it's and then on
youtube you can look up modern millie
uh show notes and links in the
description definitely take check that
out millie i appreciate you thanks for
coming on the podcast yeah of course
thanks for having me
well i hope that those tips helped you
learn how to get confident on camera and
as promised i want to give you one of my
tips and that is to smile while you're
talking what heather that's a tip yes it
is normally when you are talking in your
everyday life you're not actually
forcing a smile to happen at the same
exact time right now if you're watching
this video i am smiling and talking
through this content now if i were to
not smile and just talk at a normal pace
i would have a lower energy and i would
actually look like i'm not very happy
and here's why this can help you be
confident on camera number one it'll
increase your energy you'll have more
energy when you're smiling and talking
through that smile it'll help you to
enunciate your words more and it really
helps to lighten your face as you're on
camera number two is you look happy i
kind of alluded to that but here's the
thing people want to do business with
people that they know like and trust and
a lot of times you trust people that are
happy people so one of my confidence
tips for you is the next time you're on
video just smile and talk through your
smile and see on the other side when
you're watching that playback how much
energy you have and how nice you look on
camera so i hope that helps you the next
time you need to create your video now
here on this show one of my favorite
things to do is to read the comments
from the people who have rated and
reviewed this podcast you can do that
over on apple podcast and that helps us
get in front of other people who are
interested in this type of content it
helps me to also know that what type of
content you like listening to if the
topic is great or if you want us to go
deeper in different things and my
favorite ones to read are your
testimonies when you share with us that
you've grown your youtube channel or you
share with us that you started your
online course or you share with us that
you got that brand deal oh my goodness
that is exactly what i'd love to see
in these comments over on apple podcast
and today's review comes from uh liddy
listens liddy says
thank you only listen to two of the
first videos but i have been sitting on
this for two years one foot in and one
foot out time to go all in great content
and motivation
lydia listens left that after the uh
video that we had that was all about the
youtube domination framework and so i
want to encourage you to get all in on
video video is going nowhere it's only
getting bigger and bigger and bigger so
i'm gonna encourage you to jump in with
two feet
thank you so much for listening to this
podcast i hope that it's encouraged you
today and i want to ask you what's your
next step that you need to take what
action do you need to take after
listening to this podcast maybe you need
to set up the camera and just press
record thank you for being a listener
here on our show make sure you subscribe
wherever you are consuming this content
share it with a friend if you know that
they need exactly what we have here on
the podcast and we'll catch you in the
next episode did you hear that growth
video live 2022 is back in person this
is your opportunity to network with
like-minded people just like you to make
friendships to make business
partnerships this is your opportunity to
get in the room you can get your ticket
now at
growethvideolive.com they're going so
fast so make sure you get your ticket
right now at growthvideolive.com
[Music]
you